- our car Chester on tonight Zimmerman
says he was told he'd be testing a
sporty car with a rear engine he wasn't
expecting this though he says that
Renault believes even a pocket rocket
deserves a rear engine so he's going to
check out the benefits
the ancient sound certainly isn't going
to set a sports color lovers heart
racing with its 52 kilowatts that
twinkle crawls rather than Sprint's from
0 to 100 kilometres an hour taking 14
and a half seconds but thanks to its
optional start/stop system the Twingo
already meets EU emission norms of 95
grams of co2 per kilometer which only
take effect in the year 2020
before Tyler Andre says the benefits of
the rear engine and rear-wheel drive are
obvious as they don't have to transfer
power the front wheels can focus solely
on steering reducing the danger of under
steering and the engineers have created
another advantage in doing this it's big
steering angle makes the Twingo easy to
maneuver in city traffic the Twingo can
do a u-turn on the narrowest of streets
giving you the ability to change
directions and will of course you'll
need to keep an eye out for oncoming
traffic
Andre says the high seating position in
the Twingo doesn't make for a sporty
ride but it does produce good visibility
between those rearview mirrors right at
his eye level so he can see right away
what's behind him though in multi lane
traffic gets confusing as the mirror
hangs right in front of his face
visiting inside the Twingo is colorful
and imaginative though it contains lots
of hard plastic there's even a removable
storage bin in front of the gearshift
unfortunately the gear stick isn't very
ergonomic by contrast the climate
control system is quite user friendly
the same can't be said for the radio
Andre says his test model has no
integrated sat-nav it does have a cell
phone holder but it makes it hard to see
and use the buttons behind it put the
phone in landscape mode to use a
navigation app for instance and it
covers all the buttons using another
external sat-nav rather than a phone app
could also be problematic normally you'd
want to attach it here on the front
windshield but the cable would have to
go in the first 12 volt socket here the
Twingo is a colorful little city
runabout for the urban jungle round
daytime running lights are integrated
into the bumpers the trim at the side of
the car sports the model name and the
concept drawing of the Twingo though the
looks of the real car doesn't quite
measure up for 990 euros extra the
Twingo comes as a convertible with a
folding soft top
the one liter engine is located in the
back under the trunk vents let the hot
air escape Andre says the Twingo has 219
liters of volume more than the Opel Adam
but a little less than VW's up the
Twingo could use a bit more space as the
trunk won't close when these three
crates are put in lengthwise he says
making the trunk lid a bit thinner here
could likely solve the problem I'll
admit that's probably my shyness unglued
shift the crates to the centre of the
trunk though and the lid closes easily
as the plastic reinforcements are much
thinner there so what's Andres verdict
on the new Twingo
DeNooyer he feels it's a really great
city card it stops in terms of
maneuverability and visibility at faster
speeds he was pleasantly surprised that
unlike front-wheel drive cars
it was never unstable while braking
Andre wonders whether Renault will bring
out an RS version as he thinks this
Twingo has sporting potential